Shawn asks Gary what are your practical
hustle hacks when it comes to diet sleep
on your daily routine how do you
maintain energy and great power will
hustle a non-stop Shawn I think a lot of
that comes to do personal great picture
I mean this is you know what actually
this whole picture dynamic is gonna
really flip the switch obviously you
guys know I'm super hot and Instagram to
me I care about the attention graph
actually I want to write an article a
medium about this the attention graph
that's the whole game that that actually
probably might nugget like I win on that
which is where's the attention you know
YouTube a year after YouTube comes out
it's got attention that people don't
realize is valuable start the askgaryvee
show podcasting snapchat all right start
Wine Library TV sorry for the mix-up one
of the same it's all family the my kids
I love them both it's weirder than I
have two shows I'm like really weirded
out that I'm like going to be a person
that has two shows um anyway uh to
answer your question you know it really
comes down to loving it I you know I
the reason I'm able to continue to
hustle and and do what I do is because I
love it
I love doing a show I love flying all
over the country you know I like taking
my kind of like selfies on Instagram or
like Seth sour face and like you know
what everybody's like don't be like this
is what you want right like why you'd
said I'm not upset I just kind of fun
little pout face that I like to and when
I travel it not not just 13 year old
girls can't be the only people that's
how you know so you know I think for me
it comes down to I love it so much that
it you know here's a good answer I woke
up at 5:15 this morning after landing at
midnight on a flight yesterday to play
6:00 a.m. tip-off basketball today
because I loved it but if muscle Mike
came in to like work me out at that time
I would have been more begrudged because
I love basketball I love competition
I've come to love the working out I love
the way it makes me look I mean I've
been looking at some old videos like woo
but uh that's what it comes down to if
you truly love it if you truly love it
it doesn't feel like work all these
extra hours I'm putting into the Wine
Library stuff right now doesn't feel
like work because I love the wine retail
hustle game and so it's interesting it
just comes down to love oh crap wait
subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe